الخبر العاجل الذي ما زلتم تقرونه على
شاشتنا نقلا عن موشي كبنسكي وهو قائد
جولان الاسبق يقول ان اللواء خسر منذ
السابع من اكتوبر ربع قواته بين قتيل
وجريح اذ قتل 82 ضابطا
وجنديا يعلن فقط بان كابلين السكي هو قائد
اسبق لاركان الجيش الاسرائيلي وزار كتائب
جولان على الحدود واشار ايضا في تصريحاته
الى وقوع مئات المصابين من جنود هذا
اللواء نقرا هذا التصريح اكثر بالتحليل
العسكري مع ضيفنا من اسطنبول الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم
كريم الفلاحي عقيد الفلاحي اهلا بك اذا ما
الذي يكشفه لنا هذا التصريح لقائد جولاني
الاسبق وهو يعترف بان هذا اللواء خسر ربع
قواته منذ السابع من اكتوبر بين قتيل
وجريء
ما الذي يكشفه هذا
التصريح نعم تحيه لك ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره
نعم بدايه دعيني اقول بان هذه الحصيله
التي يتكلمون عنها من الخسائر تعطي دلاله
واضحه على شده المعارك راتها في قطاع غزه
ولكن عندما يقول بان اللواء خسر ربع قواته
بعد ذلك يتكلم عن 82 بين 82 بين قتيل
وجريح بين ضباط ومراتب هذا اشكال حقيقي في
مسقول قتل 82 ضابطا وجنديا وخسر ل جولان
ربع قواته منذ السابع من اكتوبر بين قتيل
وجريح دع بس دعين دعيني اكمل
الفكره عندما يقول بانه خسر 822 وخسر ربع
قواته هذا الكلام غير دقيق لانه عندما
نتكلم عن التنظيم نتكلم بان الفصيل تقريبا
العدد يتجاوز الفصيل العادي لمشاه 120
جندي السريه تقريبا يصل تعدادها الى اكثر
من من من من اكثر من 450 وعندما نتكلم عن
الافواج نتكلم عن قوه تصل الى الى الاف
يعني عندما نتكلم عن اللواء نتكلم عن 2000
2500 يعني اذا نقول ربع قواته في بمعنى
هذا بان عندما نقول 2500 يجب ان تكون هناك
خسائر تصل الى اكثر من 500 قتيل بين جريح
وقتيل اما ان نقول ربع القوات ثم نقول
الكلام بانه 82 بين قتيل وجريح بين ضابط
وجندي هذا الكلام غير دقيق لان اللواء
خصوصا التنظيمات الخاصه اما ان يكون
التشكيل ثلاثي او يكون رباعي عندما يكون
ثلاثي تكون الخسائر اقل يعني عندما نقول
رباعي بمعنى الخسائر اكثر من هذا الرقم
الذي قلته الان هذا يعطي دلاله واضحه على
انهم لا يعلنون الخسائر الحقيقيه لجنوده
وضباط بالنسبه للاليه خصوصا هذه الالويه
عقيد الفلاحي لو سمحت لي عندما يتحدث عن
ان لواء جولاني خسر ربع قواته هنا يت تحدث
عن قتلى وجرحى ويقول ان من قتلوا من هذا
اللواء منذ السابع من اكتوبر بلغ
82 جنديا وضابطا يعني عندما نتحدث عن
الخسائر فهو يعترف هنا بان هناك ايضا جرحى
خسرهم هذا اللواء لم يعودوا الى هذه
الجبهه للعمل في هذه الحرب وهم يعدون ربما
بالمئات وهذا اعتراف منه اهميه هذا اللواء
لواء جولاني عقيد الفلاحي وهو يعد من
وحدات النخبه في الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما
يخسر هذا العدد من قواته ما الذي بقي له
من فاعليه على
الجبهه نعم لا شك بان الخسائر عندما تكون
بهذا الحجم هي كبيره جدا بالنسبه لهذا
اللواء الذي يعتبر من الويه النخبه ويعتبر
من الالويه الخاصه التي يعتبر هو احتياط
بالنسبه للقياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
لدى لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هو
يعتبر من ضمن الالويه التي يعتمد عليها
بالاضافه الى الويه المظليين الاخرى
ويعتبر هذا اللواء من الالويه التي يستطيع
القتال في المناطق الخاصه بسبب التدريبات
وبسبب كونه يعتبر من القوات الخاصه
بالنسبه للجيش الاسرائيلي لذلك هو يستخدم
بشكل كبير جدا وخصوصا في المعارك المحتدم
او في المحاور الساخنه يتم استخدام هذا
اللواء وهذه الخسائر هي دلاله واضحه على
ان هناك ضراوه في المعارك وان هناك ك
خسائر حقيقيه في الالويه اذا كانت الالويه
المدربه بهذا الشكل الكبير ومن الالويه
التي يشار اليها خسائرها بهذا الحجم فما
بالك ببقيه الالويه وبقيه الفرق التي هي
اقل تدريبا واقل قدرات من هذا اللواء اذا
نحن نتكلم عن خسائر كبيره جدا هذه الخسائر
ستؤثر على ما تبقى من القوه القتاليه
المتواجده لهذا اللواء خصوصا اذا كانت
الخسائر في القيادات بمختلف الرتب يعني من
ملازم وصولا الى عقيد والدليل على هذا بان
مقتل قائد اللواء في الفتره الماضيه يعطي
دلاله واضحه على ان هناك اشكال حقيقي في
العمليات العسكريه التي يديرها هذا اللواء
وتديرها القوات العسكريه في قطاع شبال غزه
او في الجنوب ام حتى المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي دانيال هكاري قال واعترف بان
الجنود الاسرائيليين يمرون كما قال باوقات
صعبه يتعرضون لمواقف غير مسبوقه يواجه
الجيش الاسرائيلي امورا لم يتعرض لها من
قبل قبل ان نناقش هذه الفكره عقيد حاتم
الفلاحي ننوه ايضا الى الخبر العاجل على
شاشتنا هذهه المره نقلا عن وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يقول بصفتي وزيرا للدفاع اتحمل
مسؤوليه انجازات الحرب وتكاليفها والاخطاء
الجسيمه هذا وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يتحمل
اذا كما يقول في هذا التصريح مسؤوليه كل
ما يجري في هذه الحرب من اخفاقات
و يضيف ايضا سنواصل العمل على او حتى
تحقيق اهداف الحرب باسقاط حكم حماس واعاده
جميع المختطفين الى منازلهم يعني في ثنايا
هذه التصريحات للمسؤولين العسكريين من
وزير الدفاع
الى المسؤولين العسكريين الاخرين هناك
اعتراف بحجم خسائر كبيره في هذه الحرب
وبصعوبه التحديات التي يواجهونها في
المعارك البريه وفي الوقت نفسه يستمرون في
الحديث عن ان هذه الح
ستستمر الى اسقاط حكم حماس واعاده جميع
المختطفين الى منازلهم معنى هذا ان السبيل
العسكري هو الذي سيستمر فيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي لاعاده الاسرى لدى المقاومه ما
تعليقك على هذه التصريحات عقيد
الفلاحي نعم هذه التصريحات تاتي في اطار
الضغوطات التي تمارس على على قطاع غزه
وعلى قياده حماس وعلى قياده القسام بالاخص
يعني في مساله اطلاق سراح الرهائن
والتسليم بما تمليه اسرائيل من استسلام
المقاومه داخل داخل قطاع غزه ولكن دعيني
اقول بانه وزير الدفاع وحكومه نتنياهو
بشكل عام ومدراء الاجهزه الامنيه يتحملون
المسؤوليه الكامل عن احداث 7 اكتوبر وعن
الاخفاق الذي حصل في السابق لذا نرى بان
هذا الاستمرار والمطاوى في الحرب هم
يعرفون جيدا بان بعد ذلك ستكون هناك
محاكمات وسيحال الكثير منهم الى المحاكم
وبالتالي هناك كاصر على مساله الاستمرار
في هذه العمليه العسكريه علما بان الخسائر
التي يتكبدها الجيش الان في هذه المعارك
سواء كانت في الشمال او في في جنوب قطاع
غزه هذه الخسائر يجب ان يحال اليها الكثير
من القاده الى الى الى المحاكمه والى
المسائله القانونيه لان لا يمكن للجيش
الصهيوني ان يتحمل هذه الخسائر التي تضاف
الى خسائر 7 اكتوبر وبالتالي هذه القيادات
هي قيادات مازوم وتحاول ان تحقق شيء على
الارض لكي تداري على خسارتها التي جارت في
7 اكتوبر لذلك هو جزء من الصراع السياسي
جزء جزء من الصراع الداخلي الموجود ما بين
المعارضه وما بين هذه الحكومه التي صرح
الكثير من قيادات المعارضه بان يجب عليها
ان ترحل ويجب بقف القتال ويجب البدء
بعمليه تبادل للاسرى اذا هذه التصريحات هي
تاتي ضمن الضغوطات وضمن ايضا ضمن
الاستمراريه التي يريدون العمل عليها هذه
القيادات لاستمرار هذه الحرب شكرا جزيلا
لك ضيفنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العقيده الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي على هذه المشاركه